this is a once in their life for any
high achievers who wants to step back
and bring storm with executives from
around the world the SCP program has
lived up to my expectations top-notch
faculty that you get access to this
fantastic University and the students
that they attract to the program they
really do make it a first-class program
I think the biggest takeaway for me
would be I came here hoping to find
answers and what I learned was that I'm
able now to ask better questions I think
it's wonderful to be here
and it's ridiculous as an English person
to talk about the weather the weather is
incredible and the campus is great and
the facilities are amazing and I think
the course is run in an incredibly
impressive professional way all of us
have certain areas of strengths and we
hold them very dear this program really
takes you out of that comfort zone our
company is a very fast-growing company
and has been growing from four billion
dollars to almost ten billion dollars in
four years and we have a huge challenge
ahead all the members of the executive
committee we really have to sharpen the
saw and be ready to shape the future of
the organization and the timing was now
so we couldn't wait and of course
Stanford was world-class it was really
great opportunity to come here it is
such an unusual experience to be able to
step out of your life like this and
being a very academically stimulating
intellectually stimulating environment
coming to SCP really gave me tremendous
exposure to many people from many
industries from across the globe and
learning from them in the classroom
setting in the rigorous academic
classroom setting but also in the
discussions outside of the classroom I
think the faculty here are really
exceptional they vary of course a lot in
background and
approach and teaching style but I've
never had such an entertaining and
stimulating and high quality intensive
experience all in the same classroom
with the same professor at the same time
they are not only inspiring very
thoughtful but also highly entertaining
I have to say they are they have the
ability of bringing over very
theoretical subjects in a very lively
manner they bring to us a balance both
of what I'd consider rigorous technical
underpinnings but they balance that with
very practical examples that allow you
to take that application back to the
real-world problems that you're facing
every day you will wake up around 5:30
in the morning and participate in the
morning exercise classes start at 8:00
and typically we have anywhere from
three to five classes a day after all
the lectures and we have to have some
reading time because in the evening from
7:45 to 9:45 we have group discussions
anyone coming to this program should
really do one thing is to leave their
laptop at home disconnect entirely from
their work life and just dive into this
experience it's worth within a span of
few weeks the become a community and I
think that's sort of energy I would love
to replicate in our company I'm left
with some really really positive warm
memories people I spend time with
the learnings that I went through and
the connections that I've made that I
know for me for the rest of my life will
be something that I'll continue to
maintain a gift it's a different you
know give something I will always
remember in my pack